gentlemen let's talk about the other
console manufacturer who may or may not
be showing more than one game at e3 I
don't know who you see oh no not the pc
game show I did doing it again this yard
again this was a weird show last year it
was a weird show last year i think this
year they're doing it right before
either right before would be soft okay
and they had to bump it back they're
like oh the car was gonna run into that
we need to scale it back that wasn't
like four hours last time yeah they
finished with Sean Murray and it was a
weird thing anyway we're not talking
about PC talking about the other side of
the power line of consoles Nintendo
they're not showing the NX this year are
they though Justin are they not showing
it they've been very explicit that
they're not oh and okay it's weird
that's such a Nintendo thing to do to go
to the biggest gaming show in the world
and not bring the thing that everybody
is curious about the thing that the most
interesting thing they have working on
the thing that their biggest game is
gonna come out on next year right and
not talk about it but they are showing
the game yeah Zelda's gonna be Zelda a
launch title for the NX yeah it's not
going to be on the NX it's gonna be on
the wii u okay and then send out thats
think about it this way i like they're
they're trying to compete with so many
different people nintendo being what you
know what they are they would stand a
benefit from waiting like a month after
e3 right and just doing a nintendo
direct me like this is it this has been
part of like a very long slow crawl out
of e3 though right yeah like between
stop doing a press conference to the
direct stuff and then the treehouse sort
of being where they were the dancing
things and let's talk a little bit about
the hardware sort of aspects of this
Peter we talked briefly about it and
last week about how the there was like a
certain chipset that they were like
using that may or may not be connected
with yes so the rumor is they may be
using the tegra chip on a buying video
which has been used in their various
shield devices right and and what that
does is it allows almost playstation 3
type graphics on mobile devices okay you
sacrifice a lil bit of resolution in
some graphical flourishes but it's also
got some hardware built in to help
stream to another device or are captured
stream from another device so they were
famously streaming from a pc to these
things like over wireless and stuff and
like it's not fancy not totally dissing
to the wii u tablish not totally
dissimilar but but it worked like over
internet connections you do it locally
so you know if they go with the tegra
you could say okay that's cool and then
maybe in video will be you know
providing a stronger GPU for the console
itself if that is a thing people talk
about them having a handheld that will
be docked in a console but if Nintendo
doesn't make a serious effort to at
least be close to the power that we're
seeing in the current versions of the
new console of the modern consoles
they're fools right they can't rely on a
mobile chip compete on a console so I
don't think that that'll be the way it
works is it sometime it has to Matt it
has to have some compatibility with the
wii u which is something that we see
every every iteration of consoles that
they have some problem porting games
over making that cross compatibility
with especially on on hard on console
hardware but this has to play wii u
games because the NX is LW is going to
be a launch title for the annex as well
well yeah and they've talked a little
bit about developing middleware that
allows porting of games cross generation
and from other consoles so it it seems
like there will be a way for them to do
that it'll largely depend on the
architecture of the hardware for a while
everyone was thinking oh there's going
to go the same route as Sony Microsoft
into an x86 chip which is what you see
from like Intel in their pc line but
they might actually go Power PC which is
what we used to see in McIntosh is back
in the day right not max Macintoshes and
that provides a different sort of thing
but if you're doing that between
generations that'll help yeah moving on
to the games I mean it's not really much
to talk about except Zelda Wii U mne
Rogers is rumored that the Zelda you
will have voice acting and that you can
select whether you want to play as a
male or female character to start and
that'll be an interesting updates yes
you can hear link either go oh yeah okay
perfect yeah wait what game are you
playing so this elbow Jets volt link
looking forward to us well definitely
there's there's a reason Nintendo is
going to be able to build almost their
entire III presence I'll rounds LW
because they know that this is their
tent pole title but all of us are
excited for it and even though I don't
think that is gonna be the only thing I
they've said on record now that they're
gonna have their second day of the
treehouse live yeah talking about other
games like Pokemon go it's not gonna be
one hundred percent Zelda hmm but they
could like I wouldn't have been
surprised I I would have believed it if
the only game playable to show the only
game they talked about was Ella because
there's so much hype and excitement
around the game that is a game that
people have said I want to buy a Wii U
but i'm waiting for zelda I just hope I
don't have to use a gamepad with that
thing if they forced me to use a gamepad
for Zelda I'll be there I mean like like
as a shield or like as a sword God she
don't even giving you the idea i feel
like with Nintendo we always get the
craziest rumors because nobody really
knows and there's a language barrier
involved there as well on a cultural
buyer significant one so you know a lot
of these rumors probably no pokemon go
props gonna be shown there as well
that's that is up and confirmed that
they're gonna show Pokemon they said
that at the treehouse life they're gonna
talk about Pokemon go okay I'm gonna
talk about Monster Hunter generations ok
games there come to 3ds was sun and moon
i I don't think they said whether they
go really about sunday noon which is
really weird that they would talk about
go but not sun and moon does the rumors
weldon mother 3 might finally be getting
localized for North American markets yes
yes it is that is going to happen I
believe this so at the beginning of this
year and 3 we have a we have a
prediction zarna for 2016 oh here we go
I totally forgot about it and we're
gonna come visit revisit this at the end
of the year yeah my prediction was
mother 3 announced this year it's gonna
happen do you made that prediction two
years ago I may kiss Brittish soon every
I got here SIA yeah it came out so that
but this year it at least came out in
japan so i have strength behind me they
just have to localize it and there are
localizations there's already
translations they can totally use those
but didn't didn't made oh the guy behind
that going record is saying nintendo has
not contacted me and like any efforts
I've made have been met with resistance
Nintendo though third they don't want to
use somebody else is gonna go we'll take
care of something so there's not already
a transmits Nintendo not an intent don't
tense than 10 do and then do a last
thing on this if you had before we jump
into bethesda and ubisoft in the air and
everyone else and if you had a wish list
if you had one thing that you would like
nintendo to enhance this year what would
it be super mario galaxy 3 oh god for NX
for both both yeah i play don't we I
like my way I played on wii
let's not go crazy they don pc can't
stop me get that make it a pc hack /
what about Justin perform mother 3 i'm
being right so they've already said that
they're gonna be having some mobile
games coming out so we know we're gonna
get a fire emblem I think animal
crossing on mobile right okay cool
experiences I still want animal crossing
on Wii U I know that I am in the
minority prove this you want to be a
prisoner at home as well as on your
commute on the toilet or like invit eyes
into the mobile game and I can play my
on the wii u and my three TS and i can
just like be harvesting vegetables and
fish all the time that's dangerous Eric
tay would get into that that's why what
happened big put it on a hog it's all we
can trade vegetables yeah like a stock
in trade vegetables and realizing you
don't do it seriously you want an
apricot I gave you a peach actually none
of those are vegetables but alright
although you can't in real life we like
will know more about what Nintendo are
showing off if there is any surprises
this time next week i guess the tree has
is running the whole show right oh yeah
show some or softer waiting sendo does a
coo announces what like the day before
saturday that boom in X there you go
screw all you guys the good idea imagine
we got three hard year where revisions
in one year it'll be amazing and yeah so
let us know what you'd like Nintendo to
announce in the comments below and hit
subscribe if you want to get more hot in
3 content